okay so we'll play the game again where
uh he's trying to touch my chest okay we
going
all right so you said he kept getting
your chest all right let's see something
go
okay so some of these passes that you're
doing these these tabaki passes you're
doing they're they're okay but you don't
have uh any of your Ike or your Coq
taking his balance So eventually he's
going to get it because he's offense he
has the initiative your
reactionary at at how you're doing it
okay so you for example uh he he pushed
okay and I saw you come around very nice
okay so he pushed you didn't block him
he pushed you yielded and you came to
this one but then nothing happened to
his balance and there it
is so the same thing he comes around you
yield but there you
see so if we watch again there's two
things that are doing this hand is
already taken off balance so I could
take this one
away but usually I go here and this
hand's just
dead that's how he got
in so if he comes around I yield here
this hand was not dead even though this
he's pushing here this hand is still
doing
something there it is
right or you okay he he pushes you pass
and it goes right into there there's
your there's your Q so you
passes it's in this hand right here and
of course you can do the two together
boom you see but you can't just the your
your you have a Coq you have a
separating Force right so we're here a
separating force and you have an
adhesion Force you understand so C
separating Force
I adhesion Force but both both of them
are working towards a kazushi so I
either bring him into the front corner
or the back corner on either side back
corner front corner or you kind of
course always
go right through but you don't just stay
out in his
hands okay he's going to get you
eventually so as he passes as you go you
always take his balance there is in the
front corner he comes back and I
push boom I key project iy
project boom pop he goes whatever
boom so we'll do that one again right
here like this he goes around I take the
elbows with a CQ
projection I don't know he's going to do
something Bop there he goes in right
he's coming in
boom around we'll do it again so here is
the I key on this hand I key on this
hand C you on that hand to keep that
corner out okay then I'll bring it
around pass through the IE face and now
it's back in the C phase on this hand
and this hand over here is the iy phase
okay so you can see that you're going uh
is that what we did I don't remember
what you did okay all right uh yeah was
I was on the outside so so this hand has
a c at first this hand will have a II at
first so this hand here has an adhesion
going you see it's not blocking him this
hand is blocking him but as this hand
passes through the IE phase it's now
going to be in the CQ phase and you
could see over here is the
adhesion but both of them are working
together to take his balance
okay so you can't just be here not take
violence you can only stick and follow
for so long it's going to get you okay
and it's also not the drill all right
let's try
again all all right so you you were
talking about this will the power once
you feel like you can't get it you enter
into a contesta mindset you against
her okay so what what ends up happening
as I said is now you're in
dichotomy but it's a dichotomy that's
working through the through fear and
through a Will To Power and what ends up
happening is you you start this path of
annihilating the other okay so in this
case is where instead of one hand being
Yin one hand being Yang or in other
words one hand being iky one hand in
communion and the other hand in
separating Force Coq you have like two
just pushing hands Okay so
go right there it
was two pushing
hands pushing your thumb do you see your
thumb hooks her you're just trying to
stop her from going
okay
okay and as you fluctuate in this
dichotomy and a lot of you are doing
this you you start to go on off in the
way that you're touching her Center like
you're you're sometimes you are then you
go off because you want to save yourself
and then you go back on and so and
because you go off that's what triggers
the fear response cuz now it comes at
you in an on Rush quickly or something
you feel behind you feel overpowered you
feel they're going to get you
okay okay so first thing to mention is
uh uh then this is probably for the more
advanced okay so yinong is a theory in
relativity so that means while it is
true it's only true from a point of view
which means it's false from another
point of view Okay so so uh the way I
described it um earlier it's very
convenient and is very easy for someone
to understand because it's presented in
a binary kind of fashion but it's
ultimately not true okay because it's
relative um I let's say you're not
you're not pushing on this hand there's
no there's no energy on this hand okay
that that's not true that's not a true
statement the energy on this hand
whether there is some or is not some is
only relative to in this case the energy
in my hand you see so if I'm trying to
shove this hand that feels like no
energy you see but if I match if I match
that I'm matching it I'm matching it
matching it matching
it so in other
words this will not project you if you
relax your hand you relax you're super
super Yin if you're super Yin that will
not project you but if I go more Yin
than you you see then this hand is now
young so you going more Yin I go more
Yin you go more Yin I go more Y is you
trying to relax I I relax more you see
and then you see it's still y hand do do
you understand that okay so this is the
downside of flexing and pushing because
you're going to
make their energy in by comparison okay
and now they're always yielding to what
you're doing and so they're always in
essence countering to what you're doing
that's how they like get so slippery on
you okay so uh when I feel like for
example you try to go around my hand you
see I stay lighter and now now it's
stuck again I just stay light light
light
light whereas uh you try to go around my
hand and look you came off of my hand
okay so you go around my hand to touch
my chest right boom are you going to
touch my
chest there you going to touch my chest
touch my chest here's my chest there you
go I go light what you see I just go
light light here light and it's stuck
okay this is important because you can't
I think what you're doing is you trying
to play the other
game but you the game right I explained
over there without realizing it's partly
not true okay because it's ethereum
relativity okay so uh and that's
important because what when I feel it go
off like I don't have your Center you
see it goes off I can keep your Center
by being light you see you get it and so
it never went off although I just went
more Yin than you which made you young
okay as opposed to I'm off and I'm
always trying to catch up and try to
stop you with thumb Hooks and grips and
things like that okay so you're going to
feel that uh I I'm always in your Center
you're trying to touch my chest I'm
always in your Center even even here
always in your Center look
ft hold always in the
center so when I'm going for more no no
no for more advanced people what I am
trying to
do
is really see how much I can change any
Yin energy you're doing to Young energy
okay you got it and so to do that I
can't be in those contests so again I'm
really light here but you can't push
forward because it's a young energy only
so we keep going so you're going to see
that I use that to never be off of your
Center
and sometimes you're like oh I I can't
get this okay don't get
it but even as you push you push down on
here right can can you come in no you
can't so I can
still that way but I I didn't use it you
see I just kept it there so I I went
ahead and adhere it on this side you see
if you start pulling that back in
softness then you'll see me go soft you
see and then s i
you I reach for you at the beginning
remember so you came up uh if you didn't
pull your hand you see how I still using
it okay if you pulled your hand I reach
for you if you pull your hand into you
he into you like you did that last rep
when you come up I see connection right
away you see that so I don't want to In
The Same Spirit of don't go on and off
don't start
over come up and now we start over no
okay so once we start the game find the
game
[Music]
we'll do that one again we came here
right you went up to his shoulder and I
just use
the
and do whatever do
whatever watch that one
again so you went around this hand you
see went around this hand one more time
you did there you go and then but who
cares this
had
do that one again oh I you you're
protecting your engagement so it brought
you in you came up on my arms here right
so I brought you in you came up and
that's where the projecting en okay so
again maybe I Can't Get You Tristan pray
attention maybe I cannot because you're
just out here going like this you see so
he's out there going like that but look
I
pull he's what's he going to do he's
going to try to go back
out okay
you can use that on that it inion part
so I'm correcting lots of people here so
here it is again he's he's so balance
but look if I just take it a little
bit and before he loses all his balance
he tries something else right you can do
something else and that's when you have
Direction there
okay all right lots to work on three
different people got Corrections